before we say goodbye we'd like to play
a quick roundup truth or dare
okay we have tina sickenporia hi tina hi
okay what's it going to be a truth or a
dare okay i think
i'm gonna
do truth okay i love how you thought
about it
i have a truth i love your eye makeup
thank you you're so beautiful
the green and the pink lip your whole
choices amazing thank you so much you're
so welcome
all right so hit us yeah what's okay
truth
okay so i'm a big tv person
and if i could choose one show to bring
back revival same cast
i would go with living single oh it's 99
a world yeah
so what tv show would you like to see
rebooted or revived in 2022 facts of
life
you take the bat
the fact of life that's good
because you also get that great ensemble
yeah you know kind of like the golden
girls and sex in the city there's like
someone you identify or parts of you i
identified through the different
characters and i was obsessed i would
love to see the nanny come back i love
the nanny
good one
yeah good one and i also think what
about like little house on the prairie
but done like kind of dark you know
that show was dark it was oh hello it
had some heavy themes i saw all those
bonnets ah
i know how it went there thank you it's
so nice meeting you and ross matthews
you are so beautiful
[Music]
you